[Music]
bachelor in paradise shut down
production but a bachelor nation wedding
went on I would marry him in a
courthouse and be fine
bachelor in paradise season 3 cup 11
bass and Carly Waddell married in Mexico
over the weekend she just gets me you
know bachelor nation alumni were in the
audience including Nick vile and fiance
Vanessa Grimaldi's Tanner Tolbert and
Jade Roper Kaitlyn Bristowe and Sean
Booth Jared hi bone Ashley Iook and
Eddie and the Ferguson twins Chris
Harrison even officiated and cameras
were rolling bass and Waddell's wedding
was supposed to be part of VIP season 4
which also filmed in Mexico but paradise
production was shut down over an
incident involving contestants Corrine
elympios and Demario Jackson still it
looks like bass and Waddell had a
magical day he posted this sweet photo
to his Instagram story The Bachelor is a
parody of sorts you know it really it's
like especially paradise it makes fun of
itself makes one of us but the cool
thing is you can actually go through a
process where you find love in January
the adorable pair told et they were
already discussing kids we talk about it
a lot
[Music]
you